tremendously exciting news gravitational
waves have finally been detected here's
a brief explanation back in 1915 Albert
Einstein gave the world his new theory
of gravity the general theory of
relativity which is based on the
beautiful idea that gravity is nothing
but warps and curves in the fabric of
space-time now barely a year later
Einstein pushed this idea one vital step
further you see he realized that if
space is flexible enough to warp then it
should also be able to to ripple to
vibrate to undulate and that would mean
that if something were to jostle the
fabric of space-time it should send out
ripples in the fabric of space and it's
those ripples that we now call
gravitational waves now of course the
source of gravitational waves would not
be my hand jostling space instead it
would be some highly energetic
Astrophysical process like rapidly
orbiting neutron stars or black holes
that would send out a steady rumble of
gravitational waves or at least this is
what the theory says should happen now
how do you test this idea well the map
shows that as a gravitational wave rolls
by it will squeeze and stretch anything
in its path you see it happening here
for the earth but of course this is
highly exaggerated so you can see the
effect we do the calculation you find
that the amount of squeezing and
stretching would be tiny a mere fraction
of an atomic diameter and that makes it
pretty difficult to detect but that is
what the LIGO team has now achieved and
they did it with two detectors one in
Louisiana the other in Washington State
and then these detectors what they do is
they fire laser beams along two four
kilometer long evacuated tunnels and
when the light recombines it creates an
iconic pattern it's known as an
interference pattern but the only thing
that you need to grasp is that we're a
gravitational wave to roll by it would
squeeze and
stretch the arms of the detector and
that would have a measurable impact on
that interference pattern causing it to
shift and it's just that kind of shift
in the interference pattern that the
LIGO team has now observed the first
direct detection of gravitational waves
and this is big this will go down in the
history of science as a pivotal moment
and not just because it's another
spectacular confirmation of Einstein's
ideas which it is but rather because for
millennia we have explored the universe
using waves of light this discovery
marks the opening of a new era in which
we will explore the universe using waves
of gravity